je pense que je pourrais apporter ce que
j'ai appris pendant mon année de BTS en
terme de de compétenence je sais pas
trop la première réponse est un peu
longue mais qu'est-ce que vous en avez
pensé qu'est-ce qui vous a marqué elle
sait pas encore je pense elle n pas
assurée elle répond pas à la question
elle dit VAG elle se répète plusieurs
fois ça se voit qu'elle est pas très à
l'aise bah pour
l'entretien
[Musique]
cet atelier il s'inscrit dans un
parcours d'accompagnement qui dure 1 an
qui a pour vocation d'accompagner les
jeunes qui grandissent dans la ruralité
donc les petites villes et les villages
de France pour leur permettre d'avoir
toutes les clés en main pour faire des
choix d'orientation qui leur
correspondent parce que notre objectif
c'est vraiment de lutter contre les
factures territoriales et surtout
permettre à chacun et bien de faire des
choix en fonction de leurs ambitions de
leurs envies et de lutter donc contre
des choix par défaut
[Musique]
je trouve que c'est vraiment top parce
que ça c'est les les moments comme ça
c'est des choses qu'on fait pas avec le
système scolaire français et pourtant
c'est des choses hyper importantes ça
nous apprend à arriver dans la vie
adulte
[Musique]
je savais déjà ce que je voulais faire
je voulais faire médecine donc au niveau
de l'orientation je m'inscrivais pas à
chemin d'avenir pour mon avenir mais je
m'inscrivais plutôt à chemin d'avenir
pour toutes les autres opportunités que
ça pouvait m'offrir donc je me suis
lancé j'ai eu ma première Viso avec M
[Musique]
reine
voilà c'est bon tu
m'entends au début j'appréhendais un peu
parce que je me disais ça pe être gênant
et cetera mais avec l'ORS c'est tout de
suite bien passé elle a été là pour moi
elle a su s'adapter je suis m'adapté
aussi et donc souvent pendant pendant
nos visios on parle de sujets dont moi
j'ai besoin parlé des stages on a parlé
aussi du séjour acoustique que j'ai
voulu faire de la demande de bourse avec
chemin d'ière que j'ai
[Musique]
fait que que j'ai dit à Ines dès le le
le premier jour et le premier réchange
qu'on a pu avoir ensemble c'est de
jamais jamais se limiter et de jamais se
dire que c'est pas fait pour nous qu'on
peut pas y arriver et finalement quand
on a quelqu'un de la famille des amis
derrière soi qui nous disent mais si
bien sûr c'est fait pour toi et bien
c'est quand même un encouragement
indispensable je pense pour sauter le
part je pense que j'ai pris confiance en
moi mais j'ai surtout pu faire plein de
projets là il m' arrivé plein de choses
en un an le voyage en Australie la
bourse TL les stages le CV en fait c'est
ouais je recommande à 100
[Musique]
%